bevor das allerdings startet diese
befragung der bundesregierung gibt es
hier noch eine debatte zur
geschäftsordnung und zwar geht es da um
eine personalie die morgen gewählt
werden soll und zwar die
bundesbeauftragte für
antidiskriminierung vorgeschlagen wurde
die publizistin und pferde ackermann
allerdings ergibt ist da besonders von
der fdp fraktion kritik daran dass diese
personalie nur gewählt wird ohne
aussprache und deswegen ist jetzt
erstmal hier eine debatte
drei minuten pro fraktion angekündigt so
dass wir jetzt mal reinhören was jeweils
die fraktionen dazu sagen da wird es
halt einerseits um die art gehen wie
diese
wahl vonstatten geht aber eventuell wird
es natürlich auch um die personalie
werde ackermann gehen im vorfeld gab es
bei ihrer nominierung schon kritik an
ihr unter anderem von der cdu csu
fraktion und eben von der afg aber auch
zb von der fdp gab es für einzelne
stimmen die sie nicht unterstützen
wollen für diesen posten als
bundesbeauftragte für anti
diskriminierungs in der
antidiskriminierungsstelle des bundes
das ist eine nationale anlaufstelle für
von diskriminierung betroffenen menschen
und nun spricht aber bernd baumann zu
dieser dieser geschäftsordnung für die
fw fraktion
meine damen und herren
ein begriff wie deutsche nation sei
zutiefst vergiftet ein deutsches volk
gebe es überhaupt nicht alles nur
ausdrucksformen von weißen rassismus
auch über heimat zu reden sei in
deutschland nazi spricht der
heimatbegriff sei brandgefährlich
toxisch wie blut und boden wer sagt so
was frau werde ackermann diese person
will die regierungskoalition zur chefin
der
höchsten deutschen anti diskriminierungs
behörde machen ein so hohes staatsamt
dass es vom bundestag selbst gewährt
werden soll porter man das muss man
wissen unterscheidet prinzipien weiße
deutsche sident sie auf dauer stabil
entschuldigung mit nein ich komme nicht
in ordnung nicht zur person bietet
sondern zur geschäfts deutsche mitte hat
sie vergangenheit systematisch von der
mit migrationshintergrund der
bevölkerung david razzia tiefen spalten
die gesellschaft
integrationsforscher nennen sie eine
hass prediger in das ist ja auch meine
damen und herren die wahl muss von der
tagesordnung
wenn migranten uns deutsche als
kartoffeln beleidigen findet man das
völlig okay sie hat auch nichts dagegen
wenn man weiße deutsche einfach nur
spargel fressen end sowie die von ammann
radikal antideutsche ressentiments sieht
diskriminiert die wahl muss von der
tagesordnung
muss es ja begründen selbst
herr baumann ich unterbreche auch ihre
zeit sie haben noch eine minute 25
ich bitte sie auf angriffe zu personen
zu verzichten sondern zur
geschäftsordnung zu reden und es reicht
nicht wenn sie zwischendurch einmal
sagen das muss von der tagesordnung
runter ich bitte sie wirklich das
einzuhaltende begründung liegt in der
person warum das von der
geschäftsordnung runter muss ich kann
die geschäftsordnungs anliegen der afg
begründen wenn ich nicht sagen wohin das
liegt das muss möglich sein
und in den letzten in der letzten
veranstaltung konnte hier eine rednerin
der spd durch weg reden zur
geschäftsordnung und hat nicht einmal
das wort geschäften oder tagesordnung
gerät das möchte ich mal sagen
wir haben das problem dass wir hier eine
frau wählen wollen zur
antidiskriminierungs beauftragte die
durchweg diskriminiert deutsche
diskriminiert wenn sie das heute auf die
tagesordnung machen da können sie auch
herren in daten zum kinderschutz
präsident will meine damen und herren
wurde für mich aus
[Applaus]
wir wissen dass wir
wir wissen dass die grünen das wollen
spd und fdp unterstützen sie heute dabei
das wissen wir auch was die
tagesordnungen angeht meine damen und
herren das der eigentliche skandal
und deswegen muss er von der
tagesordnung damit dass hier sozusagen
aber deutlich ab ausgesprochen wird muss
die debatte am anfang seien noch ein
wort an sie liebe cdu sie wollen dass
hier auch ablehnen möglicherweise jetzt
auch eine geschäftsordnungsdebatte
ablehnen dass sie sich jetzt über frau
ackermann und die wahl heute auf der
tagesordnung auf regen ist eine
heuchelei das möchte ich vorab schon mal
sagen diese frau war jahrelang die
redenschreiberin von ihrem von ihrem
armin laschet er hat ja auch hier zur
kandidatur herzlich gratuliert so viel
zu cdu meine damen und herren auch die
fdp will heute zustimmen auch im rahmen
der tagesordnung wahrscheinlich gleich
wolfgang kubicki hat gesagt eine
nichtwahl von frater man würde die
gesamte koalition gefährden das heißt
die fdp macht ganz deutlich dass ihr
nicht um die sache geht sondern nur um
die macht meine damen und herren auch
heute her
sollte man heute in wirklich gewählt
werden und das zur wahl von heute auf
der tages oder zeigt das nur wie weit
radikal ideologische linken die macht in
unserem staat schon übernommen haben das
muss man deutlich gesagt werden die
einzige alternative das sieht man auch
jetzt in der tagesordnung diskussion ist
wirklich nur das merken und wirklich
jeder nur noch die afd gegen diese linke
nächste rednerin für die fraktion
bündnis 90 die grünen dr irene mihalic
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen liebe kollegen herr baumann
sie haben uns ihre
geschäftsordnungsantrag der schon länger
angekündigt darüber haben wir auch schon
im ältestenrat und auch im kreis der
parlamentarischen geschäftsführerin und
geschäftsführer gesprochen aber die
begründung die sie anführen herr baumann
ist billig und abenteuerlich und
vollkommen inakzeptabel meine damen und
herren
und dass sie hier
diese debatte diese
geschäftsordnungsdebatte anzetteln
wollen hatte einzig und allein den grund
dass sie eigentlich eine aussprache zur
person erzwingen wollten obwohl es das
gesetz so nicht vorsieht die wahl der
antidiskriminierungs beauftragte meine
damen und herren findet ohne aussprache
statt so steht es im gesetz das wissen
sie ganz genau und deswegen ist das
manöver was sie hier abziehen doch so
die schau baumann
diese debatte hier wird nur geführt weil
die afd schon die wahl der aufsetzen die
aussetzung der wahl einer person ablehnt
die nicht in ihr von hass und
ausgrenzung geprägtes weltbild passt
aber was mich schon ein bisschen
amüsiert das mich fast schon ein
bisschen amüsiert ist dass sie das
prinzip von wahlen ganz offensichtlich
nicht verstanden haben denn wenn sie den
personalvorschlag ablehnen wie sie hier
gerade lang und breit erklären konnten
dann müssten sie ja eigentlich für die
aussetzung der wahl sein denn sonst
könnten sie ja gar nicht gegen den
vorschlag stimmen und das prinzip von
tagesordnungen herr baumann das haben
sie auch ganz offensichtlich nicht
verstanden denn wenn wir jedes mal die
gesamte tagesordnung ablehnen wollen
weil uns die kruden anträge der afg
inhaltlich nicht passen dann kämen wir
hier nie zu einer tagesordnung und dann
überhaupt nicht arbeiten
es ist also vollkommen unlogisch was sie
hier machen und es ist darüber hinaus
auch noch demokratiefeindlich denn was
bitte denn was bitte und die frage
kennen sie ja mal beantworten können was
bitte ist das denn für ein
demokratieverständnis dass sie das
parlament daran hindern wollen einen
gesetzlichen auftrag nachzukommen
dass der deutsche bundestag die
antidiskriminierungs beauftragte wählt
das steht so im gesetz die
bundesregierung schlägt eine person vor
und das parlament entscheidet und
deswegen muss der punkt auf die
tagesordnung weil das ja gerade die
voraussetzung dafür ist dass wir diese
wahl wie durchführen können die lange
vakanz dieser stelle auch endlich
beenden können
also der punkt x der unabhängigen
beauftragten für antidiskriminierung
steht auf dem vorschlag zur tagesordnung
wenn sie dem zustimmen kann die wahl
hier im parlament auch ordnungsgemäß
durchgeführt werden so wie es das gesetz
vorsieht deshalb bitte ich im namen der
ampelkoalition um zustimmung zur
tagesordnung ganz herzlichen dank
alles war es hier für die grünen am
anfang hatte bundestags präsidentin
bärbel bas noch thronicke beten das ist
wirklich um die geschäftsordnung nicht
um die personalie also um die sache
gehen soll das ist natürlich schwierig
bei so einem antrag das zu trennen
thorsten frei für die integration
kolleginnen und kollegen die aussetzung
dieses tagesordnungspunktes in der
morgigen plenarsitzung
ist korrekt und entspricht den
vorschriften
die personen die dort als kandidatin von
der bundesregierung vorgeschlagen wird
ist es nicht das will ich in aller
ausdrücklich kite sagen
so wie hart sie haben es erwähnt im
paragrafen 26 des allgemeinen
gleichbehandlungsgesetzes steht drin
dass die unabhängige bundesbeauftragte
für antidiskriminierung vom bundestag
auf vorschlag der bundesregierung
gewählt wird dieser antrag ist
rechtzeitig gestellt worden deswegen
gibt es keinen vernünftigen grund warum
dieser punkt nicht auf der tagesordnung
des bundestages
gesetz debattiert und entschieden werden
soll debattiert wird er ja nicht dass es
vollkommen richtig dass steht übrigens
in paragrafen 26 auch drin und das
akzeptieren wir auch aber an dieser
stelle muss man natürlich schon sagen
dass die bundesregierung mit ihrem
vorschlag auch anlass zu solchen
diskussionen gegeben hat weil sie auf
einer stelle die mit einer hohen
legitimation versehen ist weil wir hier
im deutschen bundestag darüber abstimmen
weil wir mit kanzlermehrheit darüber
abstimmen es eben auch jedem kollegen
und jeder kollegin bei der morgigen
abstimmung klar sein muss worum es hier
geht und jetzt wundern mich natürlich
die zwischenrufe der grünen fraktion
nicht von ihnen kommt ja dieser
vorschlag deswegen macht im grunde auch
nur sind an den vernünftigen teil dieser
koalition zu appellieren und die frage
zu stellen ob der vorschlag auf der
vorschlag der bundesbank ministerin
wirklich auch ihr vorschlag sein kann
und sie damit die verharmlosung von
kleinkriminalität das bewusstsein dass
diskriminierung nur von weißen deutschen
ausgehen kann und dass es letztlich auch
mit dem politischen islam und islamismus
nicht so schlimm sein kann diese
verniedlichung und verharmlosung dafür
steht ihre kandidatin und deswegen ist
für uns vollkommen klar hier stimmen
dieser tagesordnung zu wir werden morgen
ihrem vorschlag nicht zustimmen weil er
eben das gegenteil vor zusammenführen
ist er spaltet des integriert und
deswegen ist ein schlechter vorschlag
herzlichen dank
die union hat hier noch mal begründet
zustimmung zur tagesordnung aber dann
morgen wenn über diesen
personalvorschlag abgestimmt wird wird
die union der gegenstimmen momentan ist
die wahl ab circa 16 uhr angekündigt
wenn es nicht zu verzögerungen kommt
auch das ist ja im bundestag immer
wieder usus das ist doch manchmal länger
wir stimmen nun über
bestimmen nun ab über die von der
fraktion
der spd cdu/csu bündnis 90 die grünen
fdp und die linke vorgeschlagene
tagesordnung abwehr stimmt für diese
tagesordnung dem bitte ich um
handzeichen das sind die fraktion linke
spd bündnis 90 und fdp cdu csu fraktion
gegenstimmen die afg fraktion enthaltung
sehe ich nicht dann ist die tagesordnung
so beschlossen und der antrag der
fraktion der afd
abgelehnt ich rufe nun auch den
zusatzpunkt 1 es bleibt also bei der
wahl morgen für die
bundesbeauftragte für
antidiskriminierung